in moscow this morning opposition leader
alexi navalny is back in court his
arrest
two weeks ago led to two weekends of
massive protests all over russia and now
the court is deciding
whether to keep him in prison for an
alleged parole violation
holly williams reports now on the case
and the next step for opponents
of president vladimir putin the russian
government's fiercest critic
could soon be silenced alexei navalny's
supporters were rounded up this morning
by police
outside the courthouse vladimir ashikov
is one of navalny's allies
and told us the russian political
opposition is growing
showing the cracks in the government's
rule they feel
that they are weak i think they feel
that
they're vulnerable navalny was poisoned
with the deadly nerve agent novichok in
august last year
an apparent assassination attempt he
survived after being evacuated to
germany
a recent investigation linked the
poisoning to russian intelligence agents
navalny was detained by police when he
returned to russia last month
sparking mass protests in freezing
weather
in scores of cities across the country
thousands of protesters were taken into
custody by the police
but none of that stopped navalny from
releasing this video
accusing russia's president vladimir
putin of corruption
receiving this opulent seaside mansion
as a bribe
it's been watched more than a hundred
million times
putin denies the palatial home is his
do you think the protest will continue
if navalny is locked up
the anger will only multiply
even behind bars alexey navalny could be
a powerful symbol of descent
in vladimir putin's russia for cbs this
morning
holly williams london